YOU WOULD BE FOOLISH NOT TO
SUPPORT HIM.
>> Tucker: SPEAKING OF FOOLISH
FOOLISH.
SHE IS NOT BULLISH AT ALL AND
SHE JOINS US TONIGHT.
OCCASIONALLY AS YOU KNOW WE LIKE
TO JUST --
THINGS ARE MOVING FAST.
IT IS GOOD TO PAUSE AND THINK
ABOUT WHAT THE WORLD LOOK LIKE
SIX BUCKS AGO.
PEOPLE WERE TOUTING THIS MAN HAS
THE WOMEN'S CANDIDATE.
>> OH, BOY.
THE ONLY THING MISSING FROM
MICHAEL AVENATTI'S LINEUP IS
THAT HE HASN'T EATEN DIRT YET.
MAYBE HE CAN ADD THAT IN HE HAS
SOME TIME.
WHAT I REALLY ENJOYED WAS YOUR
INITIAL COVERAGE OF THIS FOOL
WITH THE FACT THAT HE APPEARED
TO BE EXPLOITING ONE OF HIS
CLIENTS STORMY DANIELS.
HE WAS MAKING MONEY FROM HER AND
SHE WAS REDUCED TO DOING TOURS
OF STRIP CLUBS IN THE PROCESS OF
HIM REPRESENTING HER.
THAT IS WHAT IT SPOKE TO.
>> Tucker: I SAID THAT TO HIM
AND I'VE ALWAYS FELT SORRY FOR
HER.
I HAVE NEVER DOUBTED MOST OF HER
STORY FOR THE RECORD.
I'M NOT EMBARRASSED TO SAY THAT.
I FELT BAD FOR HER AND HE SAID
FOR STRIPPING IN SOME SAD CLUB
IN VIRGINIA WASN'T ACTIVE FEMALE
EMPOWERMENT AND HE ACTUALLY SAID
THAT.
>> OBVIOUSLY NOT.
WHEN YOU ARE SEVEN YEARS OLD,
SHALL BE A 7-YEAR-OLD SAYS WHEN
I GREW UP I WANT TO BE STRIPPING
AT SOME CLUB IN VIRGINIA.
NO GIRL SAYS THAT, THAT IS NOT
WHAT WE ASPIRE TO.
MS. DANIELS HAS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO REMAKE HERSELF.
SHE HAS HAD PROBLEMS WITH HIM AS
WELL AND IF ALL THE CHARGES WERE
TRUE THEN THIS GUY IS LIKE THESE
LEG OF CRIMINALS.
HE IS TRYING TO ADJUST FOR WHAT
SEEMS TO BE INVOLVED AND SO MANY
DIFFERENT KINDS OF BEHAVIORS AND
CRIME.
IT COULD BE EXPLAINED BY A
COMMENT HE MADE TO THE VIEW.
THEY ASKED HIM EXPLICITLY,
SOMEHOW IT WENT TO ONE
SOMEHOW IT WENT TO HNE
SOMEHOW IT WENT TO HIS FANTASIES
AND THEY ALL INCLUDED HANDCUFFS.
IT LOOKS LIKE HE HAS GOTTEN ONE
PART OF HIS DREAM FULFILLED.
>> Tucker: YOU ALWAYS GET WHAT
YOU WANT IN THE END, DON'T WE?
>> HE ADAPTED TO EVERYTHING
AROUND HIM AND THIS FELLOW SEEMS
TO BE IN COMPETITION WITH
SOMEBODY.
FOR ALL OF US, I WISH THAT HE
WOULD HAVE BEEN THE PERFECT
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE ONLY IF ALL
OF THIS THEN CAME OUT IN THE